we're constantly asking how long we have
to wait for things and
uh in the context of probability theory
it turns into the technical question
called the expected time to failure or
the mean time to failure some examples
might be that an insurance company wants
to know for a given policyholder the
expected time before that policyholder
dies
uh a mechanical engineer wants to know
the expected time before
a button that's being pushed once per
second is expected to fail and i want to
know when the part that my body shop has
been waiting for
is expected to come in
okay
the meantime to failure problem we can
formalize in terms of flipping coins
so we're going to flip a coin until a
head comes up and we're going to think
of a head as being a failure and a tail
is a success
so let's assume the probability of
getting a head the probability of
failure is p
again this is not a fair coin it's a
it's a
coin that may be biased in either
direction
and let's let f be the number of flips
until the first head comes up the the
number of flips until the first failure
and if we're counting as flips is time
it's the time to fail
so what we'd like to know is what's the
expectation of f what's the
expected number of flips before a head
comes up well let's do some in order to
calculate that expectation we need to
know some probabilities so what's the
probability that f equals one well
that's the same as saying that that's
getting ahead on the first flip it's the
probability until you get an h
uh that you get just an h on the first
flip and that has probability p okay
what's the probability that f equals two
well that's the probability that you
flip a tail and then a head
and that has probability q times p
because we're assuming the flips are
independent so it's the probability of a
tail which is q times the probability of
a head which is p similarly the
probability of
f equals 3 is the same as the
probability of flipping tail tail head
and it's q squared p and of course
the uh probability density function of f
the number of steps until you'd flip
ahead
at n the probability that you have to
flip uh n times before you get the first
head is q to the n minus 1 p by the way
a random variable with whose probability
density function has is is this value is
called a geometric distribution they
come up all the time
all right so what's the formula for the
expectation of f it's simply of course
by definition it's the expect it's the
sum over all the possible values of f
which in this case are integers n
greater than zero of n times the
probability that f equals n
we figured out that the probability that
f equals n is q to the n minus 1 times p
and now i'm going to observe that we
really do know how to evaluate this sum
easily enough i'm going to factor out
the p and it becomes a sum over n
greater than 0 of q to the n minus 1
times n and then i can simplify matters
if i replace
n by n minus 1
and then i get a q to the n power so
this is equivalent to p times the sum
over n greater than equal to zero of n
plus one q to the n
now this
is a familiar generating function
it's simply equal to
uh one over 1 minus q squared as we've
seen already
so in short the expectation of f is p
times
1 over the square of 1 minus q well
so let's pull them together there of
course 1 minus q is p
so it's p times one over p squared or
one over p
and we get this really very clean answer
the expected number of flips before you
get ahead is one over the probability of
a head so for example with a fair coin
where p is a half the expected number of
flips until you get the first head is
two it's one over a half if you had a
biased coin where the probability of
getting a head was uh one and three one
third then in fact uh the expected
number of flips until you got ahead was
three
okay
um that's a nice clean answer but we got
it in this way that doesn't really give
much intuition
so let's look at another naive way to
derive the expected time to the first
head without having to worry about
generating functions and all that
sophisticated stuff about series which
is easy to forget
so let's look at the outcome tree that
describes this experiment of flipping
until you get the first head so starting
at the root uh with probability p you
flip ahead immediately and you stop
or with probability q you flip a tail
and then with probability p you finally
flip the head and stop
uh if you haven't flipped the head he by
the end of the first second step then
that is a possibility that you with
probability q flip to tail and then
there's a possibility that you stop
after the third step with a head and so
on that's how this tree goes
now
the looking at the structure of this
tree it's an infinite tree but it's very
repetitive in fact if we call the tree b
then what we're seeing is that this
whole subtree is a copy of b so now i
have a nice recursive but very finite
description of this whole infinite tree
b is a tree that has a left branch of p
that uh that ends in a leaf
or a right branch with probability q
followed by a repeat of the tree b
so now i can apply total expectation to
find the expectation of f
f is the expected number of steps i make
in this tree until i finally make the
left branch to an h
how do i figure out what the expected
time in the tree is until i make that
left branch of flipping ahead finally
well using total expectation what i can
do is
branch on whether or not the first flip
is ahead
so the expectation of f according to
total probability a total expectation is
going to be the expectation of f given
that the first flip is ahead times the
probability p that it is ahead
and the other term
is
that
it's the expectation of f
given that the first flip is a tail
times
q the probability that the first flip is
a tail
well let's look at well first of all
let's look at this term what is the
expected
number of flips until you get a head
given that you've got a head well it's
1.
so this term is easily taken care of we
understand that one
what about this term this is the
expected number of flips
until you get the first tail
um
sorry it's the it's the expected number
of flips until you get the first head
given that your first step was a tail
well what that means is that we are here
after the tail and we're asking what's
the expectation of f the number of flips
that you get starting at b
when you do
one flip that takes you to the start of
b again
and the answer is obviously 1 plus
the expected number of flips in b which
is expected expectation of f in short
this term the expectation of f given
that the first flip is a t
is a tail is simply 1 plus the expected
number of flips that we're trying to
figure out now look at this i have a
very simple arithmetic formula now
expectation of f is 1 times p plus 1
plus f times q
there it is
and now i can solve for e of f
well just taking a quick look at this
this is going to be q this is going to
yield a q term and p plus q is 1 and
this is going to be q times e of f
and there's an e of f there
if i pull the e of f over i'm going to
do a little arithmetic i'm going to
leave the rest to you and realize again
that the answer is what we had before
the expectation of f is equal to 1 over
p
so let's do one more almost silly
example for fun to remember what the
significance of one over p is
uh suppose i'm thinking about the stace
space station mirror now it's spinning
around
uh and there's a lot of garbage out
there that it's likely to hit a lot of
space junk and
suppose that based on our previous
statistics and and estimations of the
small sort of small stuff that has been
hitting near that it could survive
that we estimate that there's about a
150 000 chance that in any given hour
it's going to run into some
intolerable uh collision with a with
space junk or a meteor that's going to
destroy it so suppose the space station
mir has a 150 000 chance of destruction
in any given hour so how many hours do
we expect until destruction well it's
one over a hundred and fifty thousand or
a hundred and fifty thousand hours which
tran
so much facility space station examples
let's wrap up with an intuitive argument
that could be made rigorous but i'm not
going to because i think it's clearer
just left in this informal way that
makes it
intuitive why you would expect that of
course the expected time to failure is
one over the probability of failing on a
given flip
well
how many failures do you expect in one
try well by definition it's the uh
expectation of
getting a head on the first flip it's p
okay now if you flip n times
you expect to get
n times as many
failures as you'd expect in one try so
the expected number of fails in n tries
is n times p that's an intuitive
argument in fact it's the rigorously
correct argument remember that if we
flip n times we're counting the number
of heads in n flips that's a binomial
distribution we already figured out in a
couple of ways that its expectation is
np but never mind that
it's just sort of i think it's
intuitively clear that if you expect p
heads in one try and you do n tries that
are all independent you're going to
expect to get n times p
failures okay or heads
now
what's the expected number of tries
between failures well if you think about
that i've done n tries
and i've got np failures so if i divide
the number of tries by the number of
failures that by definition is the
average time between the failures it's
the expected time to a failure so i
divide the number of tries by the number
of fails which by definition is the
average number of tries between failures
and it's equal to n over
np
which is equal to one over p
and that's an argument that i hope you
will remember